et vous recevez la télé par une antenne
râteau pas de panique il faut juste
vérifier si votre télé est prête pour le
passage à la tnt hd la tnt ça nouveau
nouvelle naissance pour lcp on parle
beaucoup de la révolution technologique
que ça représentait cette possibilité
d'avoir 17 18 20 27 ch est gratuite mais
surtout c'est pour ceux qui arrivent
une exigence programmatique et donc il
fallait que que lcp deviennent cet objet
télévisuel attractif grand public à la
faveur de la tnt
nous venons de presser le bouton qui ait
symboliquement marque justement ce
basculement dans le numérique c'est à
dire 18 shon à meyers ont une meilleure
image
je crois vraiment une nouvelle étape de
l'aventuré les visuels
moi j'arrive à la direction de l'antenne
et des programmes de lcp à ce moment là
c'est le premier discours que je tiens
aux équipes ici en disant mais vous avez
un truc génial qui vous arrive
attention c'est un cadeau formidable si
la chaîne ne se transforme pas comme
elle doit se transformer à la faveur de
cet été ça peut se retourner contre vous
[Musique]
qu'on pouvait plus se contenter
simplement de mettre trois personnes
autour d'une table de poser des
questions et cdh a donc fallu sortir
fallait aller voir la france fallait
aller voir le monde ils sont maintenant
pour quelques instants l'hémicycle
l'hexagone et les ministères direction
l'inde avec cette délégation
parlementaire française partis
rencontrer le dalaï lama
il y avait une équipe de jeunes
journalistes passionnés et c'est moi
j'ai fait le choix de l'heure de
construire une espèce d'alchimie avec
des gens plus aguerris des figures de
l'audiovisuel bonjour à tous une bonne
manière de décrypter la culture
le contrat c'est le nom de cette
émission
ono masure giesbert pulvar thomas hervé
john paul lepers etc etc
[Musique]
c'est évidemment un grand débat qui a
beaucoup agité ce qu'ils ont pensé lcp
est-ce que d'un côté on doit être une
chaîne très parlementaire très vertueuse
très sérieuse et de l'autre côté une
chaîne dévergondée commercial non on
doit être une chaîne qui s'empare d'une
matière encore une fois la matière
parlementaire la matière politique la
matière citoyenne et c'est ce travail
d'équilibriste dirais entre l'un et
l'autre qui fait des choses qui sont ici
peu ça fait pas d'écho efficace ion
multiplicateur en termes d'audience
géniaux mais on sent que le truc bouge
et surtout on sent que l'image de la
chaîne hbo
finalement cette chaîne s'était
construite comme une espèce d'exception
et là elle redevenait aussi une chaîne
parmi les autres
[Musique]